hay más de 70 millones de personas
sordas en el mundo que usan más de 300
lenguajes de señas distintos son
lenguajes completos con tantas
complejidades lingüísticas como los
lenguajes hablados no todos los usuarios
del lenguaje de señas son personas
sordas muchos hijos de padres sordos lo
dominan mientras que muchos niños sordos
no lo aprenden o no del todo
correctamente en francia por ejemplo
sólo alrededor de un tercio de las
personas sordas pueden usar las señas de
forma fluida
cerca del 90% de los niños sordos tienen
padres que si oyen así que a menudo los
propios padres no saben usar el lenguaje
de señas y los niños necesitan una ayuda
externa para aprenderlo una ayuda que no
siempre es accesible
la convención de naciones unidas sobre
los derechos de personas con
discapacidades declara que los lenguajes
de señas tienen el mismo estatus que los
hablados y obliga a los estados miembros
a facilitar el aprendizaje del lenguaje
de señas una premisa incumplida en
muchos lugares según la federación
mundial de personas sordas 66 países han
alcanzado el reconocimiento total de sus
lenguajes de señas nacionales lo que
implica legislaciones que reconocen el
derecho de las personas sordas a usarlo
en todos los ámbitos de la vida las
personas sordas padecen desigualdad de
acceso a la información ya la
comunicación en su día a día sobre todo
en el ámbito educativo una brecha
agravada por la pandemia a nivel mundial
sólo cerca del 2% de las personas sordas
acceden a la educación a través del
lenguaje de señas a menudo por la falta
de intérpretes y de recursos